president Trump returning to the
campaign Trail after his indictment on
37 felony criminal charges including
repeated violations of the seldom cited
Espionage Act and over the weekend he
hit the campaign Trail he took aim at
the charges called them baseless and
claimed he might even benefit from them
politically and according to our latest
polling he may be right about that CBS
News has learned in the poll released
yesterday that he continues to be on
solid front runner ground in the race
for the Republican nomination 61 percent
support among likely Republican primary
voters Robert Costa is outside the
federal courthouse in Miami where where
Trump will be arraigned that is
scheduled to happen tomorrow Bob good
morning
Good morning Tony sources close to
Trump's legal team tell me that when he
arrives here on Tuesday he plans to
plead not guilty and those sources say
over the weekend Trump in private was
frustrated and defiant telling advisors
that even if he's convicted he will
never leave the presidential race
as far as the
joke of an indictment it's a horrible
thing back on the campaign Trail this
weekend former president Trump railed
against the Federal indictment as a
political hit job I mean the only good
thing about it is it's driven my poll
numbers way up Trump is facing 37
criminal charges among them prosecutors
say he illegally retained classified
documents detailing U.S nuclear weapons
programs and details about military
activity and capabilities of both the
U.S and foreign countries special
counsel Jack Smith spoke after the
indictment was unsealed are laws that
protect National Defense information are
critical to the Safety and Security of
the United States
and they must be enforced in the filing
pictures show what the indictment says
are sensitive documents found in a
bathroom a public ballroom and Spilled
Out on a storage room floor at Trump's
Florida home during the 2016 campaign
Trump repeatedly hammered Hillary
Clinton for her handling of sensitive
material and his own words are included
in the indictment we can't have someone
in the Oval Office who doesn't
understand the meaning of the word
confidential or classified on Sunday
Trump's former Attorney General Bill
Barr said he was shocked by the amount
and sensitivity of the documents
mentioned in the filing if even half of
it is true then he's toast I mean it's a
it's a pretty it's a very detailed
indictment and it's very very damning
meanwhile many of Trump's political
allies defended him over the weekend
Donald Trump you may hate his guts but
he is not a spy he did not commit
Espionage We Gather here in North
Carolina after a Saturday for America
and as for his Republican rivals in the
2024 race many were quick to attack the
justice department instead of the former
president attorney general Merrick
Garland stop hiding behind the special
counsel and stand before the American
people and explain why this indictment
went forward
Trump is expected to travel to Miami
tonight where City officials are
preparing for possible protests and
bolstering security on Tuesday after the
arraignment Trump plans to head back to
New Jersey to his golf club where he
will deliver a speech and huddle with
his major donors Gail
all right Bob thank you very much